انتقل الان الى مراسلتنا نجوان سمري من
غلاف غزه نجوان على ما يبدو ان لديك جديد
او تطورات
جديده او لو تسمحي تحديدا ما اقصده عن
المواقف الاسرائيليه حيال ما نشرته
نيويورك
تايمز بالفعل يعني لو اردنا يعني التمعن
قليلا ببيان الجيش الصادر قبل قليل والذي
ينفي ما جاء في صحيفه نيويورك تايمز فهو
امر متوقع يعني الجيش الاسرائيلي رسميا لا
يستطيع ان يعلن بشكل رسمي بان هذه
العمليات على بالاساس في موضوع الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه لن لم تحقق
ولن تحقق اي شيء على صعيد الافراج عنهم
ومن المتوقع انه بطبيعه الحال سينفيل هذه
التسريبات او هذه التصريحات التي نقلت عن
مسؤولين عسكريين وامني في نيويورك تايمز
ولكن ايه من المؤكد ايضا ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي سيواصل سعيه في محاوله لو
يستطيع فقط ان يصل الى اي من الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه ويعيده حيا
وليس اي بعد ان يقتل كما حدث في مرات
سابقه هذا واحد من اهم الاهداف التي يريد
ان يحققها الجيش فقط لاستعاده ايه القليل
من هيبه الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي حتى الان
لم يحقق اي من الاهداف الاستراتيجيه لهذه
الحرب كذلك الوصول الى قاده الفصائل فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهذا ما جاء اليوم في
مقال في صحيفه معريف لاحد المحللين
الامنيين ان الجيش سيواصل سعيه ليس فقط من
اجل تحرير الاسرى وانما من اجل احراز اي
صوره نصر له في هذه الحرب لكن حسابات
البيدر تختلف عن حسابات الحقل غنوه لذلك
جاء هذا النفي لكن لو نظرنا لمن كتب هذه
او من نقل هذه التصريحات عن مسؤولين في
الجيش الاسرائيلي في نيويورك تايمز هو
رونين برجمان وهو احد كبار المحللين
والكتاب للشؤون العسكريه والامنيه
والاستخبارات في اسرائيل وبالتالي من
المؤكد بانه نقل هذه التصريحات عن مسؤولين
عسكريين عرف جيدا كيف يصل اليهم وكيف هم
ايضا يتعمدون ايصال هذه المعلومات له اذا
هي تسريبات بالفعل من مسؤولين سياسيين
وعسكريين لنيويورك تايمز والكاتب فيها هو
بالاساس كاتب اسرائيلي يكتب ايضا في
نيويورك تايمز لكن من الواضح ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا يستطيع الاعتراف رسميا بمثل
هذه التصريحات و سينفا لكن ايضا نعود
ونذكر ان واحد من الشخصيات البارزه في
مجلس الحرب الذي ادلى بتصريحات مماثله
تعكس حاله الاحباط لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي
غير المعلنه بشكل رسمي هو جادي ايزنكوت
وهو رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش السابق تحدث
قبل يومين في مقابله مطوله جدا مع قناه
التلفزه الاسرائيليه الثانيه تحدث فيها عن
جوانب مختلفه سياسيه و عسكريه فيما يتعلق
بهذه الحرب على غزه وقال حرفيا ان من يقول
في هذه المرحله بعد اكثر من 100 يوم على
هذه الحرب ان باستطاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
تحقيق هذه الانجازات وتحديدا قضيه اعاده
اسرى محتجزين في غزه في عمليات عسكريه وهم
على قيد الحياه يكون واهما ويقول الكذب
ويخدع الاسرائيليين لذلك قال انه يجب الان
التوجه الى ابرام صفقه تبادل لانها
الطريقه الوحيده بعد ثلاثه اشهر من القتال
اخفق فيها الجيش نم من احراز اي تقدم في
هذا السياق يجب تحقيق فقط صفقه تبادل
للافراج عن الاسرى وعن امور اخرى متعلقه
بسير العمليات الحربيه